Showtime in IMAX you'll see 26% more
picture so we are going to play the IMAX
26% more gay how exciting
here we go this is it if you could have
26% more helicopters 26% more
motorcycles in this film which we do you
want I really love the motorcycles I'll
go for that 26% more helicopter pilots a
helicopters no discussion
maybe helicopters just because those
aerial sequences are insane the
motorcycles because I liked I just
couldn't believe that he actually did it
in Paris
and I had like two minutes of shoot it
if you could spend 26% more time with
someone from this film who would it be
all of them it's really difficult each
and everyone in their own way all the
ladies are really pretty cool pretty
badass Christopher McQuarrie Rebecca
Ferguson because she's my buddy Michelle
Monaghan Rebecca because I love her
she's really cool would you want to be
26% ROM girl or 26 percent faster at
this point I would say stronger I'm
gonna say stronger 26% faster I actually
won the dads race in sports day 26%
faster
definitely I wanted out to run atomic
cruiser so I go 26% stronger Corey
stronger 26% faster would require
strength to get to that what Tom Cruise
character would you want to be 26% more
like my thunder because he can dance oh
good Vincent from collateral like
maverick because flying jets would be
fantastic well it would have to be Ethan
Hunt
if it visa why not
[Music]